this next question is a simple harmonic
motion question which is generally
something we would regard as relatively
simple in the context of the extension 2
course indeed simple harmonic ignition
used to be a solely extension 1 result
or concept but this one has a twist in
it which is one of the reasons why when
we actually attempted the question uh in
practice we all well not all of us but
the vast majority of us fell down on
something very simple at the end of the
question so let's have a look together
a particle moves along a straight line
according to the equation x double dot
equals minus 16 x so here is our
acceleration equation right here so
let's just put a box around that
x is the displacement in meters at time
t seconds and then they give you some
conditions they're not initial
conditions because there's actually no
mention of time really you can see this
differential equation that's been
provided here just relates our
acceleration to our position our
displacement
and they say if the particle is at rest
when x equals seven find the velocity of
the particle when x equals two and the
particles moving toward the origin okay
so a bunch of bits of piece of
information here okay for starters let's
just go back to this differential
equation here x double dot equals
minus 16x one of the things you can
immediately know from this is that this
tells you even though it's not
explicitly stated in words that this
movement is centered on the origin
otherwise you'd have 16x minus something
to represent the shift in x so i'm going
to say that the center
is going to be at x equals zero which i
read straight off of the equation
and then the second thing which i kind
of you know used to help me out with
forming an equation in a second is that
we've got this piece of information
actually let's use a different color
that the
the particle is at rest at x equals
seven or when x equals seven so what
that tells you is if your center is at x
equals zero and you're at rest at x
equals seven um this this mirror
equation here tells me i'm in simple
harmonic motion and this tells me like
when you're at rest is one of the
extremities of motion so if you're going
from the center all the way to 7 then x
equals 7 is going to be the furthest
away that you can get and of course you
can go in the other direction you can go
to x equals negative 7 but this is going
to be i'm just going to flag that as my
extremity okay
i guess another way of saying it is that
this is the amplitude of motion it can
go 7 units either way and since i'm
going from the origin that's why you end
up at 7 negative 7.
okay lastly what's the actual question
well what they want is the velocity
that's what i need to work out but i
want the velocity at a particular place
when x equals 2 and the particle is
moving towards the origin so kind of
funny they give us this two-sided piece
of information here and you'll see why
in a second both of those bits of
information the position and which
direction you're going in why that's
important
now there's a few different ways to do
this i'm going to write down first this
is part e
and we'll start by just writing that
differential equation like so
like we saw in earlier motion questions
that were not simple harmonic motion
whenever you've got an acceleration
equation and you want to get up from
there into velocity there's a bunch of
different ways to go about it you know
there's all of the time equations we've
already seen in this in the context of
this question they're not going to be so
relevant um here you've kind of got two
candidates right and we've already
discussed them in earlier questions we
can either go via
the half v squared result or we could
use
the v dv on dx result either of those
would be suitable okay
now in the context of simple harmonic
motion you can actually take if you take
this left-hand resolve here
this result here actually lands you on a
specific kind of formula after
integration that is particular to simple
harmonic motion it's always true if you
have this same kind of oscillating
behavior
and that result is that
v squared is equal to n squared outside
of a squared minus x squared where
v is velocity n is uh about the the
period of motion or the frequency and
you can see in this case n would be
equal to four
and then a is the amplitude which
already signaled earlier because we're
going around x equals 7 and we go as far
as x equals 7
then a would be 7 that would be the
amplitude of motion okay now because
this is a simple harmonic
question i can just sort of appeal
straight to this result but before we do
that because maybe you're looking at
this and it's been a while since you've
looked at simple harmonic motion you
might say but where does that come from
um why is this result true why can we
just pluck it
out of the middle of nowhere
you can plug it at the middle of nowhere
because it's a proven result for simple
harmony motion but let me show you um
its origin okay
so if we consider oopsie daisy and i'll
just leave this in blue as an
explanation of um
this particular general result and then
we'll bring it to the specific question
x double dot equals minus 16x
in a moment if we just consider some
specific or rather some general simple
harmonic motion like so right so for any
arbitrary n
if we take as i mentioned this result
over here um this half v squared right
what i can say is if i substitute that
in and then perform some integration um
if i'm careful you'll get that v squared
from here right
so therefore if i just go ahead and
write d on dx
of half v squared is equal to minus n
squared x at this point it's fairly
normal to just say yup you know i've got
that derivative with respect to x on the
left hand side i've got a function of x
on the right hand side let's go ahead
and integrate i'm just going to do one
teeny step before that which i hope
you'll see is going to help me out
especially in view of where i'm headed
and what i'm going to try and simplify
toward what i'm going to do is just
before integrating
i'm going to multiply both sides by 2
and that kind of serves a dual purpose
in the first instance you can see on the
left hand side it just gives me the v
squared which i will eventually make the
subject over there
and then the secondary thing is knowing
that i'm about to integrate i've got an
x there but by multiplying by 2 what you
can see that does is turns into
something which is ready to integrate
even more easily than x was 2x of course
it integrates straight up into x squared
like you saw here okay so let's go ahead
and do that integral i'm just going to
get v squared
is equal to the minus n squared is just
a constant coefficient the 2x integrates
up into x squared just like i discussed
and of course this is an indefinite
integral so i need a constant
integration
i mean in the context of this question i
could just say plus c like i usually do
but in this particular instance because
i'm talking about simple harmonic motion
which has a center of motion and that's
usually denoted as c i'm just going to
use a different letter so i'm just going
to call that capital b
and i'm going to indicate that that is
a constant like so
all right so the question then becomes
well how do i work out what that
constant is what can what sort of
information do i have and if you go back
to the original question you can see why
i'm leaning in this direction
if you go back to notice that there's
the particle at rest when x equals 7 you
can take that at rest fact right there
that tells you that velocity equals zero
and pair it up with this x equals seven
to evaluate my constant which in this
case is b so i'm going to say let's just
go back over here
but
you know in this sort of general term um
rather than saying x equals seven i can
say x equals a for the amplitude of
motion right
when
x equals a for amplitude the velocity is
zero because you've reached the
extremity of the motion right so
therefore i can say
0 squared which is 0 is going to be
minus n squared a squared there's that
substitution right there
okay so you can see where i'm putting
the a into and then you've got b hanging
out there so clearly from here that
constant is just going to be equal to
add this to both sides n squared a
squared
so what that tells me is when i
substitute this result back into this
line right here you can see i e
v squared equals minus n squared x
squared plus this constant that i just
evaluated and squared a squared and
hopefully if i go all the way back you
can see all i need to do from here up to
here
is factorize out that n squared and of
course because the x squared has this
minus attached it seems fairly
reasonable to make it the second term
rather than the first term okay
so this is where that result comes from
let's actually just use it for this
result right
in this question
in this question
i can say
because i've got simple harmonic motion
i can go straight to v squared equals i
already know what n squared is it's
going to be 16 in the context of this
question so i'll go 16 and i'll say
the a squared in this case will be
7 squared so i'll get 49 minus x squared
since x equals 7
is an extremity
right so you can see i'm i'm showing
that i'm substituting this result into
here so it's not just coming out of thin
air right
and from there i just need to answer the
question they asked what will the
velocity be when
x equals 2 and also you're heading back
towards the origin okay so let's just
actually substitute that in
when x equals 2
velocity squared equals 16 outside of 49
take away 2 squared which is 4
that's 16 times 45
that is going to be 16 times 45 is the
same as half this double that 8 times 90
which is 720 so i've got v squared
equals 720
so that velocity um if i take out what's
going to be a square number in there
that's going to be
144 so if i take that out that will be
12 square root 5
if i take the square root but don't
forget
this is not the only one that you can
square up to get 720 you're going to get
both the positive and the negative
versions of this okay
so i've got v equals plus minus 12 root
5 and we're finding ourselves in a very
familiar place even in this exam itself
we were we encountered this kind of like
our fine velocity the velocity function
in terms of displacement and if you go
via this v squared path you get this
plus or minus that you have to deal with
once you take the square root and we've
mentioned before you've got to deal with
that plus minus you've got to be able to
work out which one isn't
in terms of a function like do we have
some information that tells us i'm going
in this direction or that direction
in this case here this is why that
second piece of information was provided
to us in the question let's just go back
it says
find the velocity of the particle when x
equals 2 well that part is done i've
already substituted that in gotten a
value
and the particle is moving towards the
origin now this is the part that either
people just completely ignored or they
got confused by the particles moving
towards the origin from x equals two now
think about this right if i were to just
draw a quick and dirty sketch like so
well it's not even straight let's uh
let's fix that up
oh it's really hard to get
that'll do okay there we go um please
forgive me gods of the diagrams right
i've got my center at x equals zero
there's seven i'm not even going to
worry about the negative side because
i'm really interested in that point two
and what the velocity is at that spot
right now this is simple harmonic motion
so i'm getting this oscillating back and
forth and back and forth
i could say i mean this is x right i
haven't been told it's horizontal so i
can't say left or right but i can say
it's moving sometimes in the positive
direction and sometimes in the negative
direction and that is what these two
answers correspond to right sometimes
i'm moving towards that extremity and
sometimes i'm moving away from that
extremity right so you can see this is
going to be in the positive direction 12
root 5 meters per second and this one
over here will be in the negative
direction negative 12 root 5 meters per
second
which one is it and the question tells
us when you are moving back towards the
origin so that's why i can note it's got
to be this one i can exclude this
positive result because it's not moving
back towards the origin so i would
conclude by saying
since
particle
is moving toward origin
from x equals 2
if you wanted to be really explicit
i'm going to exclude the positive result
from here so i'm going to say v equals
negative 12. oopsie daisy my pencil is
playing up a little bit let's try that
again v
still being funny
negative 12 root 5 meters per second
there we go okay so this was tricky i
did say simple harmonic motion itself
isn't too dramatic but the curveball in
this question is
if you just sort of excluded the
negative result just out of reflex
because the positive result is often the
one that we want then you would have
gotten this exactly wrong but even if
you excluded the positive result
correctly but didn't say why that also
was not justified right so
it wasn't a show that question so you
might have gotten away with it just
getting that negative but i don't see
why you wouldn't even if you don't have
a diagram make a statement about why
you're excluding the positive one rather
than the negative because it's a little
bit unusual to do that
okay so
let's have a look at the next question